A GREAT YEARE TRACKS SPACE.
THE OFFENSIVE SIDE OF IT.
>> Brendan: CALE MAKARTER STEP.
HE TAKES THE PASS FROM RANTANEN.
IT'S A GREAT PLAY. MAKAR.
DELIVERED ON CARRY IT IN.
ON THE MOVE.
I HAVE A FEELING CALE MAKAR IS
AND THIS ONE SLIPS ON BY AND A
CHANCE TO CATCH UP TO IT FOR
OFGOT A WORKLOAD.
EVERY ICE IS A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT.
YOU CHANGE THE
11-8 IN FAVOR OF
HE ACTUALLY  WELL.
GIRARD.
GOOD CHANGE OFF THE ANAHEIM
DUCKS ARE STARTING TO PICK IPRE.
TOEWS STILL THERE AS THE PASS
CAME BACK TOL OFF THE BOARD.
BACKHAND TO THE FRONT. LANDESKO.
RANTANEN GET A PENALTY
KILL UNIT TO FIGURE OUT WHERE
'.
!
SAM GIRARD FOUND A PASSING PUCK
DIFFERENT WAYS.
THAT'S WHAT THE FANS WANT.
THEY WANT TO SEE DIFFERENTT IN
REFEREE TREVORT IT UP HIGH
ENOUGH TO THE BLOCKER SIDE B TO
ESCORT IT FROM DANGENATIONAL HO
FOR THE GAME-TYING GOAL.
RAKELL LOST IT SPEED.
LOGAN O'CONNOR ON GOAL FOR ANAH
THAT POWER PLAY.
STILL A 1-0 LEAD FOR COLOL.
OH, BOY.
OH, OHND THE NET, LOOKING FOR
SOMETHING.
THE LINE FOR JOHNSONM.
COMING AFTER MAKAR.
GIRARD WAS
E
OKAY.
>> Brendan: THAT ONE TOOK GO
AND LOSE THE GAM
DEFENSIVE END.
COMPHEO
26-8-3, ON THE ROAD 10-6-2.
GONE
BENCH AGAIN AS THE DUCKS WILL
TRY ONCE MORE TO